Thanks I mean really hello that's how he
brings you out okay but a well deserved
ah well dessert yes I argue well dessert
I'm getting ready to come out feeling
pretty good about things Sifl never ever
himself yeah yeah high praise India uh
look oh oh how about this GQ magazine
released their list of 10 most stylish
men hmm I always get excited when
there's a list because let's just say
the list is long like infinite okay
chance I might be on it oh but they have
their GQ magazine and their list of 10
most stylish men oh this is fascinating
take a look this congratulations to
justin timberlake who has named the most
stylish man in america by GQ in the
closest voting in our history second
place went to David Letterman he cute
butters help you become Kage
what are they talking about now at time
for a segment we have been doing for
almost 30 years we like to call it so we
do small town near
they can be cool
News 8 days views are debuts pop star
you know I just say thank you fall if
you're about to come out on stage take
the great stage here at the elaman
theater a lesser man hears himself being
described as syphilitic it's a chance
you might I want to go out really nah
nah not you so here